der august wird der youtube monat nicht
nur das youtuber treffen auf der
gamescom der video.de nein auch eine
geniale youtuber party im atrium in
dingolfing mit dabei sind flying the
white city die super asia brothers mit
schenk und meine wenigkeit christoph
krachten von klicks um zusammen sind das
600 tausend abonnenten und es gibt was
zu gewinnen ich haue zehn cds aktuelle
und cds meiner gäste raus und dazu zehn
gratis tickets für diese partie wenn ihr
gefällt mir bei klickst du auf facebook
also facebook.com / pixum klickt und
unter dieses video schreibt wo diese
party statt und einer der höhepunkte
dieser party die versteigerung dieses
verschwitzten hemd das habe ich beim
interview mit natalia kills getragen und
sie hat ihr autogramm draufgesetzt sieht
er gerade unterwegs mit lmfao in den
charts mit campaign schauer und unter
einem champions stehen wir dann auch
endlich auch in dingolfing mehr drauf
bis dahin und turbo xxl du bist auch
dabei
ja ja ja